Okay, so today we continue the topic of
secret societies. Last class we
discussed how they come into power.
Today we're we will look at where they
come from and what they believe.
Okay? So to understand secret societies,
I first need to explain to you the
history of religion
in the Western world.
So in the Western world, there have been
three major stages
of religious development.
And again, I will oversimplify
for the purpose of clarity. Okay? So
this is a
simplified version of the history.
So the three major stages of religion
develop of religious development in the
Western world are the Mother Goddess,
Mother Goddess,
uh polytheism,
and monotheism.
Polytheism means many gods. You believe
in many gods. Monotheism means one god,
that only one god exists.
So the Mother Goddess civilization
um came about because of agriculture.
And in an agricultural
world, you have two problems. The first
problem is to make sure that your crops
are healthy and you can harvest them in
time. Second problem is
to give birth, to have as many children
as possible to work the fields.
Okay? So these are the two problems. And
because of that, a religion developed in
order to facilitate facilitate both,
called the Mother Goddess civilization.
So the center of this religion is the
womb.
The woman's womb is considered a divine
portal from the spirit world into our
world.
It's almost like a cave,
right? In which the spirit world can
come out and manifest itself in our
world. So the center of this religion is
the womb of the woman. And as such, the
woman are in control.
What's really important is to understand
that in this world, everything is
interconnected, harmonized, balanced
together.
So the womb is a center of this world,
but then you have the stars.
Okay? The stars.
And of course, this gives rise to
astrology.
Astrology
is the study of the movement of the
stars in order to understand it's a it's
impact on our world.
Okay? Then you have of course
um
the crops.
Right? So in an ideal world, all three
are aligned together.
By studying the stars, you know when to
best plant the crops and when to best
have children.
And in this world again, it is the woman
who are in control. They have the high
status in society because they believe
that women are direct representatives of
the Mother Goddess
who rules the world.
Usually in this society, the Mother
Goddess is represented as a bird.
Okay? A bird.
Why? Because if you think about it,
if you study all the animals in nature,
it's the bird that has dominion over the
sky.
And if life comes from the sky, it makes
sense that the Mother Goddess must be a
bird of some sort.
But uh the Mother Goddess is also paired
with a bull. Okay? A bull. Why? Because
a bull is a symbol of virility
and energy.
You cannot You cannot get pregnant
as a woman by yourself. You need a man
to do it for you. Okay? So the bird and
the bull are the two symbols of worship
in this world.
Now, this world is very strange from our
perspective because there's no property.
Everything
belongs to everyone.
There's no hierarchy. Everyone is the
same.
And there's no
such thing as
um
m-
as sex by yourself. Okay? So sex is
actually a community act. So there these
rituals um called fertility cults,
fertility
cults,
in which
they have sex together. In fact, many
men will have sex with one woman. It
makes sense because as a woman, you want
to have the best DNA.
You You want to have the best sperm,
right? You don't know who's going to
have the best sperm, so you just have
sex with everyone and whoever has the
best sperm will give it to you.
Okay? So that's the Mother Goddess
civilization.
Then we switch to polytheism.
So why do we make the switch? The answer
is
war.
For the first time in human history, as
populations increase, there's now
struggle for resources.
And what's the most important resource
in this world? Do you guys know?
The most important resource is
woman, right? Females. Because it's
females that give birth. And that's the
And so with war, we have a new concept
called property.
In order to get men to fight wars, you
have to give them something as reward,
right? So they get to have a woman, a
wife. And now this wife belongs to them
and only them.
So in this world, what happens is that
you now have property,
hierarchy, and marriage.
And the role of the woman decreases and
the role of the man increases.
Okay? At the same time,
what's happening is that
these different societies, in order to
fight wars, they have a god.
Okay? And when they go to war,
they it's like the gods are going to
war.
And if you lose the war, what it means
is that your god is inferior to their
god.
So now you have a hierarchy of gods.
So to maintain peace, what happens is
that if you lose the war,
you admit that your god is weaker than
their god and you
you now must obey their god.
Right? And this is what we call the
pantheon.
So remember in the Greek pantheon, Zeus
is at the top and then you have Apollo,
Ares, Aphrodite. Okay? Everyone else is
a lower god.
But before, they were separate gods. And
in a series of wars, the people who
believe Zeus is the best god won out
against the other gods.
And as a result, the other gods became
Zeus's children. Yes? Do you have a
question?
Um why does
like the men the men fight for women but
women don't fight for men?
Like the women don't um
fight for the men. So why?
Okay.
Okay. So the question
um is why do men go to war and why don't
women go to war? Okay. So
that's a really good question. Okay? So
let me explain to you very slowly.
So in this world, the woman are in
control.
Right? So women have all the status.
But over time, as populations increase,
you have a
you have young men who have no
families. And these young men are
discarded from the societies because of
lack of resources.
So these young men have a problem. They
need to find wives in order to survive.
So these young men start to raid other
societies in order to capture women.
Do you understand?
So in this society, it's never young
women who are discarded because they
they have value to their society. It's
always young men who are discarded. And
as a result, these young men become like
wolves. Okay? They become like a wolf
pack who then go and pillage other
villages. And that's how you start And
that's And that's how you have the
origin of war. Okay? Does that make
sense? Yeah. Okay. So now,
you have this pantheon
of gods.
Okay? Which leads to polytheism.
Then we make the switch from polytheism
to monotheism. Why? Because now you have
a new idea called empire.
Specifically, the Roman Empire and they
introduce a new religion called
Christianity, which is the first
monotheistic religion in the world.
There's a lot of debate
um as to what was the first monotheistic
religion. Some people say
Zoroastrianism. Some people say Judaism.
I will I will show you in this class
later on that actually the first
religion that was monotheistic is
Christianity, okay?
So, the difference between between the
society where which is a society based
on war is you still there's a lot of
humans, but humans are still the most
precious resource.
Therefore, it is not in your best
interest to kill everyone.
But we have an we we we have an empire
like the Roman Empire, you don't have to
worry about killing other people. In
fact, you can go and destroy entire
societies, which is what the Romans did.
And you can now as an empire enforce,
impose your reality, your God on
everyone else.
And that's how you have monotheism. Does
that make sense?
All right. So,
having explained that, what I want to
show you now is
how the world view, our understanding of
the world, changes over time.
Okay? So,
in the
mother goddess
civilization, there are two things about
their world that's very different from
our world, okay?
So, the first major difference, this is
this is really important for you guys to
remember is
they understood that
mind led to matter.
Mind
leads to matter.
But in our world, we believe that it's
matter
that led to mind.
Okay, do you understand? So, in science
class you're taught we have a brain,
then the brain because of synaptic
connections creates the mind.
Okay? So, it's matter that leads to
mind.
Um
even though we're taught this, if you
think about it, it actually doesn't make
any sense.
Because how does our small little brain,
how is it able to do so much processing,
which is the mind, right? How are how
are we able to imagine? How are we able
to dream?
It's really confusing for us. And quite
honestly, if you talk to the very best
neuroscientists in the world,
they their response will always be
don't ask this question.
Okay? It's never like we don't know,
it's always like don't ask this
question.
Okay, this question is forbidden to ask
in neuroscience.
But so, throughout most of human
history, we believed that it was mind
that led to matter. That it's the mind
that creates the brain in order to
understand the world. Okay? That makes a
lot more sense than mind
uh matter leads to mind, okay?
Okay, so that's the first major
difference. Throughout most of human
history, most societies believed that it
was the mind that creates the brain.
The second major difference is that this
is a metaphorical
world. In other words, they spoke using
metaphors. They understood the world
through metaphors.
Today, we live in a literal world.
Okay? What's the difference? Well, the
difference is this.
Let's just say that you and I fight.
Well, we would say that okay, what
happened was that
um I became angry.
The emotion overwhelmed me, and then I
hit him, then he got angry, then he hit
me back, okay? This is a literal
interpretation. But back then, the
metaphorical understanding was that
anger is a god who seized me and who
propelled me into the fight. And then
anger unleashed the god of vengeance who
fought back by seizing the other person
to fight me back, okay?
So, we believed for most of of human
history that we were controlled by
forces outside our control.
Now,
today, you may believe that the literal
world makes more sense, but if you think
about it,
from the perspective of human thought,
okay? How do you understand the world?
How do you um interpret what goes on in
the world? The metaphorical
understanding is actually much more
useful. And that's why, and and I know
this is hard for you guys to understand,
back then, they were much more creative
than we are today.
Okay?
And also, the things that they were able
to do
are beyond our imagination. So, for
example, we've never really figured out
how the Egyptians created the pyramids.
Okay? For our explanation is aliens did
it. Because their mind is beyond our
imagination.
Okay? So, that's the that shows you
the switch. Now, when we when we when we
go to the polytheistic
um
world, this system still continues, but
they add more elements to make it more
complex, okay? So, the first element is
they believe that we are controlled by
God. We are the playthings of gods. Now,
what's really important to understand is
that these gods, Zeus, Apollo, Ares,
they're no different from
mortals. The only difference is they
just live forever.
Okay?
So, for example,
if you are a king,
what do you like to do? Well, you like
to go around and chase young girls
around, okay?
What does Zeus do all day?
What does Apollo do all day?
These gods, all they do is go around and
chase young girls around.
Okay? So, there's actually no
difference.
Above the gods are the older gods,
fortune,
fate. So, the belief was that even
though these are gods, they're still
controlled by forces beyond their
understanding understanding like fortune
and fate.
What mattered in this world was not to
be good,
what mattered in this world is to be
lucky, okay? To be fortunate. Because
that showed you that that the gods
favored you.
And the last element, the most important
element, is the unwritten
and immutable
laws
of the universe.
Okay? So, a concept like justice.
So, think of gravity, how gravity gives
structure to the universe, right? Well,
back then they believed the same thing
where at the at the at the most
fundamental level, there were concepts
that existed like justice.
And if you you could have the favor of
the gods,
and you could be very lucky, but if you
did things that were unjust, then
eventually you would be punished
for it because you're breaking the
structure of the universe.
Okay? So,
this was the polytheistic worldview.
Now, when you go to the monotheistic
worldview,
all this changes because now you have a
new concept that never existed in human
history before called one true God.
And this changes everything, okay?
Because before as you can see, humans
thought in a very complex,
sophisticated,
diverse, imaginative way about the
world. But now with the with the advent
of Christianity, it's only one true God.
And as such, you have three new concepts
that become dominant in this world.
These These concepts have existed
before, but now they're dominant. The
first concept is the idea of truth.
Okay? If there's one true God, then
there must be one truth to the universe.
And so, when we move towards the truth,
that is good, right? But when we move
towards when we move away from the
truth, that is evil.
So, now you have a new concept called
evil that that that didn't really exist
before.
Okay? You did good things because in
this world, it was to your advantage.
Now, in this world, if you defy God,
that is evil.
Okay? And now with truth and evil,
you have a new concept called the
individual.
Before in this world, what mattered was
your family, your community, your
society, the people around you. Now,
with the advent of one true God, the
community the family doesn't matter.
What mattered is your loyalty,
your faith in the one true God. So, you
can actually step outside your community
and just do what you believe is right as
long as you have faith in the one true
God.
All right?
Okay? So,
this three concepts, truth, evil,
individual, are important for you to
remember because they underpin
modernity. These three concepts, once
they grow to a certain extent, they will
create modernity, the world we live in.
Okay? Our world is controlled by these
three
forces.
Now, what's important for us to
understand is these three concepts are
beyond the human intuition.
You cannot logically by yourself deduce
or come up with these three concepts.
This world of the mother goddess, it's
intuitive.
Okay? This polytheistic world is also
intuitive, but the Christian world now
is counterintuitive.
Okay?
So, as a result, um for monotheism to
triumph because it's so counter
counterintuitive, it must now destroy
the polytheistic world.
Okay? So, the Romans
spent a lot of time, taking centuries
and centuries, to destroy the
polytheistic world.
But the thing is this.
You can never ever kill an idea.
The idea, if it is being suppressed,
just goes underground. Okay? So,
remember here in the mother goddess
civilization, the main instrument of
religious worship are fertility cults
run by women.
Well, now that
war has come and men have taken over
from women, what happened is that the
women went underground to create new
religious organizations called mystery
schools.
And mystery schools,
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to maintain the best knowledge
and traditions of the mother civilized
the mother goddess civilization.
Okay? Especially the fact that we come
from the mind.
We created the universe from our
imagination. Okay? That's the main
secret that they're trying to maintain.
These mystery schools become actually
popular among the elite because they
offer great sex. Okay? The elite join
these mystery clubs as sex clubs,
basically.
Um
Remember, in this civilization,
what matter is the womb. So, they
develop all sorts of like secret sexual
techniques to please the woman to make
the woman feel as though she's in
harmony with the uh
uh universe. In this world the mother
goddess, sex is a mechanism to
communicate with the universe. To
discover the secrets of the universe.
And so, they maintain these rituals in
the mystery schools. The most powerful
people will participate in these mystery
schools. They're called mystery schools
not because they're secret, but because
everyone is sworn to secrecy. So, if you
um ever divulge what actually goes in
these mystery schools, you'll be
punished by death. Okay? You'll be
executed by the members.
But with the advent of Christianity,
these mystery schools now are threat
to the empire. Okay? Because these
mystery schools are where the elite the
local elite hang out. So, now what
happens is now they become secret
societies.
Okay?
That's where they come from.
Secret societies are an attempt to
maintain the secrets of the universe
against the advent of Christianity and
empire.
And secret societies have been around
for long, long time. You may have heard
of certain secret societies like the
Knights Templars, Rosicrucians,
Illuminati the Illum- Illuminati, the
Freemasons. Okay? They're all very
powerful. They're still around. Yes, I
understand that. But what I'm saying is
there are a lot more secret societies
that we do not know about and have been
around for much longer. Okay? But
they're all trying to maintain the
secret of the universe, which is that
mind leads to matter. That's the great
secret of the universe. And this is
something that we've always believed and
always known, but with the advent of
Christianity,
this has been become suppressed over
time.
All right?
So, any questions before I move on?
Okay. So, now what what I will do is
I'm may I'm going to explain to you
Christianity.
And I'll explain to you what these
secret societies believe. Okay? I've
I've I've already explained to you where
they come from, but now what I will do
is explain to you what they actually
believe about the universe.
Okay.
So, what I'm going to do is first thing
I'm going to do is explain to you
what most Christians believe about the
religion. Okay? This is called the
orthodox
or the canonical
perspective.
Okay? So, this is what you're taught
officially by the church.
Christianity has many different
factions, but they all they believe in a
certain interpretation of the Bible.
Okay? Then what what I'm going to do is
I'm going to show you the apocryphal
apocryphal Apocryphal which just means
hidden, okay? Or secret or esoteric.
Just a secret
knowledge that is kept within these
secret secret societies.
All right.
So, the orthodox canonical comes from a
reading of the Bible.
And the Bible at its core is a story of
the covenant between God and humans.
Okay? Covenant. Covenant means contract
or understanding.
So, throughout
the Bible,
there are a series of covenants. Okay?
The first covenant is between Adam
and God. So, you may have heard of the
story of the Garden of Eden, right?
God creates the universe, then creates
the Garden of Eden where he puts Adam
and Eve. And God says to Adam and Eve,
"This is paradise. You don't have to
work. Just enjoy life. The food is free.
The food is plentiful.
Every day you'll be happy and free of
um want. You will live forever.
But there's only one thing that you must
not do. And only one thing. Okay?
Whatever you do, do not eat
from
the tree of knowledge of good and evil.
Just don't do that and you'll be okay."
So, of course what do Adam and Eve do?
They eat the stupid fruit. Okay? So,
then what God does is he banishes Adam
and Eve from the Garden of Eden and now
they're forced to work
to to grow food to feed themselves.
Okay? And this leads to
um society. Okay? Development of
society.
God looks down from
uh the heavens and sees that humans now
are going to war.
They are fighting their private
property. And God says, "I don't want
this crap. This is not why I created
humans. Okay?" So, he's like, "You know
what? I'm going to I'm I'm going to
destroy everyone and start over." But
then he sees a human that he likes named
Noah.
And this leads to
God saying to Noah, "Build a ship. Build
an ark and save yourself because I will
flood the universe. I will destroy the
world." So, God God destroys the world
and Noah lives. And then God says to
Noah, "You know what? That's kind of
silly. I shouldn't have destroyed the
universe. I promise never ever destroy
the world again." Okay? That is his
covenant with Noah.
But God sees that humans are still
wicked and evil. He says, "You know
what? I need to find a man who is good.
And I I need him to grow a nation
that can be the light of the world. That
will be the best example of what it
means to be a good person." So, he finds
a man named Abraham. And Abraham, of
course, is the father of a nation called
Israel.
And so, this is the third covenant.
God says to Abraham, "You and your
children and your
uh grandchildren and your
great-grandchildren are now loyal to me.
I see you as the chosen people and I
give you the promised land." Okay?
That's what Israel is, a promised land.
Over time what happens is that Abraham
and his people they go off to Egypt.
And in Egypt they become slaves to the
pharaoh of Egypt. And then God is like,
"You know what? I should check up on the
Israelites and see how they're doing."
He looks down and says, "Oops. They're
now slaves to the pharaoh. So, I I need
now to fix this. Okay?" So, he appoints
a man named Moses
to free the Israelites from Egypt and
take them back to the promised land.
When Moses does this, God says, "Now
what you must do is give the Israelites
my law, the Ten Commandments."
Okay? The law. Because otherwise, I
can't trust you guys to behave.
Okay? So, now this is the fourth
covenant.
So, now the Israelites are back in the
promised land, but again,
and even though there's laws, they still
become wicked and they start to worship
false gods. So, God punishes them and
God is now looking for a good leader of
the Israelites. And then finally he
finds a person named David
who becomes the king of the Israelites
and God says to David,
"You are the person I've been looking
for all eternity. You are the best
example of what it means to be a
faithful follower of me, Yahweh." Okay?
And so, this is something called the
Davidic covenant. The Davidic covenant
states that God will always favor Israel
as the chosen nation. And the house of
David will rule Israel forever.
Okay?
So, guys, quick question here.
Who wrote the Bible?
Probably this guy. Okay? Right? If you
had to guess who wrote the Bible,
probably not Moses, probably not
Abraham, probably not Noah, probably not
Adam, probably this guy. Okay? Because
he's saying that all of these five,
okay?
I am the best.
I'm the I'm the person that God loves
the most. My family
will rule the world because that is
God's will. Okay? Now, of course,
that that's how it happens. Eventually
David has a son named Solomon and these
two are considered the two best rulers
of Israel. And this is what we call the
Davidic Kingdom, okay? The Davidic
Kingdom, the golden age of Israel. But
after Solomon,
the Israelites turn wicked again and
then God has to punish them and
scattered Israel across the world.
Okay?
And so, the last covenant is the arrival
of Jesus.
What Jesus does is that
first of all, he reasserts the law
of Moses and and say to the Israelite
people, remember Moses and his law,
because that's what God wants.
Then, he sacrifices himself
in order to free Israelites of the
original sin.
Right? Because God's pissed off at
people because people
ate the fruit.
That's the original sin.
That's the first crime of disobedience
against God. So, by killing himself,
Jesus frees humanity of the original
sin. He redeems humanity.
Okay? The last thing that Jesus does is
he creates a new covenant, okay? A new
covenant
between humanity and God.
From now on, because Jesus has freed
everyone from the original sin,
everyone
can now
be with God. You don't have to be
Israelite, you don't have to follow the
Mosaic law, you don't even have to come
from the family of David. Anyone and
everyone can now
love God and God will love that person
back, okay? And this, of course, starts
Christianity.
All right? So, this
guys, is called Judaism, what the Jews
believe.
Okay? And this is all six is what
Christians believe, Christianity.
All right? The first five covenants are
what Jews believe to be true.
But they do believe that eventually
someone will
return to restore the kingdom of David,
okay? But not Jesus.
Not Jesus.
The Christians believe that Jesus is the
final prophet.
Okay? In fact, Jesus is God himself.
That's why it's called Christianity.
Because they believe in Jesus Christ.
So, this is the entire history of
Judaism and Christianity.
What they believe, officially.
Any questions before I move on?
Okay? But now, I just going to
understand, if you are a true Christian
or you're a true Jew, there are actually
lots of issues with this understanding.
Okay? The first issue is
um
why did God have to kick us out of the
Garden of Eden?
I mean, was eating a fruit so bad as to
banish us from paradise? Like, what was
wrong with eating that fruit, okay?
That's a great mystery in the religion.
Why did the original sin happen and why
was God so angry?
Second problem is Noah.
I mean, like
God destroyed the world because we were
wicked, but after he destroyed the
world, we were still wicked.
So, why did God have to destroy the
world in the first place? If he's God,
then she then shouldn't he understand
how humans are? That wouldn't he
understand that destroying the world
would just I mean, it doesn't really do
anything, okay?
So, that's kind of strange.
The last problem is Jesus.
Um who was Jesus?
And why did he have to kill himself?
Why did God have to send his only son to
die for humanity?
Okay? So, if you're new to Christianity,
the very idea of Jesus actually doesn't
make much sense
to you. I grew up in the West, I grew up
in a Christian world and it never made
sense to me, okay?
People told me about great Jesus was,
like, okay, the story doesn't make any
sense.
So, if you're really smart person, there
are lots of there are lots of questions
about this interpretation of the Bible
and these are the three major ones.
Okay? So, now what I what I will do now
is I'll explain to you what the esoteric
what secret societies believe really
happened.
Okay? So,
I want to start with Noah.
Why did God destroy the world? The
reason why God destroyed the world is
not because of humans, but because of
something else. These people are called
the Nephilim, Nephilim.
Okay, um also, by by the way, um if you
guys are interested in learning more,
there are two books that are not part of
the Bible, but which will give you
insight into the esoteric knowledge,
okay? The first is called the Book of
Enoch.
Book of Enoch.
The second is called
the Gospel of Thomas.
Okay? All right. So, I am using these
two books as sources for my explanation,
okay? So, the Nephilim
are
children
of
angels and women. Okay? So, what
happened was that
um the angels were supposed to watch
humanity
came down and saw, wow, these human
humans, these females are really
beautiful. So, what do they do? Well,
they have sex with them.
All right? And then what happens? They
have lots and lots of children. And what
do these children do? These children
enslave humanity. These These people are
called the Nephilim, okay? So, if you if
you want to understand what happened,
let's do a thought experiment. Let's
just say that
there's this group of superhumans called
the Avengers. You know, Spider-Man, Iron
Man, Captain America, Thor, okay? And
they fight Thanos and they save the
world. And now what do they do? Well,
they're bored, so they start to have
lots and lots of sex. They have lots and
lots of children and these children now
are like demigods, right? So, what do
they do? Well, they enslave humanity,
but then what do they do? Well, they
start fighting amongst themselves, okay?
So, that's basically what happened.
So, God had to destroy
the Nephilim because
they are not natural.
Angels and humans are not supposed to
have sex with each other and like this
creates a new
um power called the Nephilim. The
problem though is the Nephilim are
divine and therefore they cannot be
killed.
So, you can kill with their mortal
bodies, but now they become
demons
who live underground and are in the
shadows.
And guess what, guys? They're still here
today.
So, these esoteric societies, they
believe the Nephilim are real and they
still control the world. The richest
people in the world
are actually
Nephilim.
Okay?
Because they've been around for
thousands of years and therefore they're
able to control the development of
humanity. Okay? So, they're called the
Nephilim. So, that's easy to understand.
But now the question then is, wait a
minute, why did Adam eat that apple that
fruit and why did Jesus have to kill
himself? Well, now it gets really
complicated, okay? So, now I need I need
to explain to you what the secret
societies believe, okay? Remember, they
believe that mind leads to matter. What
does that mean? Okay? Let me explain
what this means, mind leads to matter.
In the beginning,
the true God is called the Monad.
Okay? The one.
So, just think think of this as the core
of the universe, the sun, the divine
sun.
The Monad is so powerful that when he
breathes, okay?
He vibrates divine energy. And over
millions of years, this divine energy
creates new life forms. Okay? So, the
first life form I'll call the Dyads.
Dyads are just
pairs, okay? Usually male, female that
are children of the Monad and they're
able by themselves to create new
universes as well, okay? So, the Dyads
start to emanate, emanate, emanate,
emanate, emanate, emanate, okay? So, so
the entire universe is vibration, it's
vibrational energy, it's it's the
breathing of these cosmic beings.
Okay? And over time, over millions of
years, these vibrations become atoms,
which then leads to matter, okay? That's
what they mean by mind leads to matter.
Now, one of these Dyads
named Sophia
decides, you know what?
I can be just as good as the Monad. What
does the Monad do? The Monad is able to
propagate by itself, by himself. He
doesn't need to mate. So, Sophia Sophia
says,
you know what? I'm going to produce
something by myself. I'm going to have a
child by myself to prove I am the Monad,
okay? So, she does this and she creates
a new being, okay? A new being. Which is
called the Demiurge. There are different
names, we'll call him the Demiurge.
The Demiurge is a monster, a
monstrosity,
because it goes against the natural
order. Then Sophia is like, oops, I
shouldn't have done that. So, so what
does she do? She abandons the
monstrosity. She throws him away and
hides him in a sea of clouds. So, no one
knows he actually exists.
Okay? Even the Demiurge doesn't know he
exists.
The Demiurge does not know about this
world, right? Therefore, he believes
that he must be the one true God
capable of creating new life. So, what
does he create?
Us.
Okay? He creates the planet Earth.
And then he and then
he creates Adam and Eve.
Okay? That's what a monster would do,
okay? Look at this history. What kind of
God would kick someone out of paradise
for eating a fruit? A monster would do
it, right? What kind of God would kill a
people for no particular reason? A
monster would do that.
Okay? What kind of God would demand that
a that a people be loyal to that person?
A monster.
What kind of God would enforce his will
on a people?
A monster.
What kind of God would say to someone,
"You're the one person I like, everyone
else I hate." A monster would do that.
Okay? So, in other words, the true
secret
that these secret societies are trying
to keep is the God we worship today is
the false God.
It's the And we are actually in a prison
created by this false God.
And that's who Jesus was. Jesus was a
cosmic being sent by the monad to tell
us the truth about the world. And that's
why he died, because the Roman Empire
could not allow
people to see the truth. If I told you
the truth, you would know it right away.
You would wake up.
Therefore, the truth tellers must be
killed.
Okay? So, that's what these secret
societies believe. They believe that
the monad exists and the mind of the
monad is what creates creates the
universe.
And Jesus was sent to remind us that
even though we're in a prison, there's
still the monad in you. There's a spark
in you, a divine light in you that you
can activate.
And if you activate it, then you will
return to the monad. You will see the
truth for yourself.
And when you die, your soul, which is
part of the monad, will want to return
to the monad and escape this world. But
to activate this light,
you must be a good person. You must love
one another. You must reject money and
materialism and grades, okay? Grades
in school.
You must reject competition. You must
reject
material wealth
in order to pursue spiritual happiness.
Okay? That was the message of Jesus.
Now, you can imagine that
the powers that be,
the Nephilim, would not like this, okay?
It's a threat threat to Nephilim who now
control the prison created by the
demiurge. It's also a threat threat to
the demiurge. And that's why
these secret societies have been
over the centuries been repressed, been
executed. Okay? Been massacred. But they
believe that it is their duty to protect
this secret, because only by protecting
this secret can humanity be ultimately
saved.
Right?
Does that make sense?
Okay? Any any questions?
Right? So, you have the official
version, which is what you're taught in
school, but now you have the secret
version that is only taught in secret
societies.
The other thing about these secret
societies that's really important is
they believe that most of us cannot
accept the truth. If I told you this,
you'd think I'm crazy and report me to
the police.
Okay? Therefore, they can only wait for
people to wake up by themselves and
approach them. And if if you approach
them, then they will test you
and then they will reveal the secret of
the universe to you.
Okay? And that's why these secret
societies
were founded and that's why they've been
so persistent and so successful over the
centuries.
Right?
So,
now the question is, okay, this is a
great theory, but how do we know it's
true or not? How do we know that this is
actually what they really
thought?
Well, we know because
in poetry,
in literature,
the members of these secret societies
have embedded the secret within the
poetry. So, if you're able to analyze
the poetry properly,
you will see for yourself that this is
true. Okay? So, what we're going to do
is we will study
today the greatest poem in English
language called Paradise Lost by John
Milton, who was who actually was a
member of these secret societies.
Okay?
Any questions be be be before I um
continue?
Okay.
Okay. We're we're we're we're we're
going to be doing Paradise Lost, okay?
Are we clear?
Any questions? Yeah, there's there's
there's a question here.
Um if all of these are from the false
God, do we have a like true God? Like do
we? Or like is just a
thing? Okay. Yeah. So, in this system,
the monad is the true God.
Okay?
And the question then is
why doesn't the monad interfere?
Why doesn't the monad stop the demiurge
from imprisoning us and making our lives
hell?
And
um
there are two explanations for why this
is happening.
Okay? The first ex- explanation
is that the monad does not interfere in
material affairs.
Okay? Because the monad is all it's all
mind.
And also, we have the capacity to reject
this world and return to the monad.
Right? So, why would he force us
to
um
do what we don't want to do?
Okay? If you want to return to him, then
you have the choice to engage in
spirituality,
to engage in goodness,
to engage in knowledge, and then you'll
be able to return to him, okay? That's
the first explanation. Second ex-
explanation is that
and this comes from Dante, okay?
The monad is a force that is eternal,
perfect, and immutable. And therefore,
the monad has no imagination.
But how do you grow as a being? You grow
through the imagination.
So, in order for the monad to continue
continue to grow,
the monad
allowed for the demiurge to create human
beings.
Because as human beings, we are flawed,
we make mistakes, we commit evil. But by
committing evil, by
making mistakes, we expand the
imagination of the universe.
Okay? Which allows the monad to to
expand, okay? So, in this perspective
Sorry Sorry, in this perspective,
what is happening
is that
each time we imagine,
we return to the monad.
Okay? So, so um it's hard to understand,
but the monad it's there, it's eternal,
but it's also becoming. It's also
moving.
And so, when we imagine things, when we
commit mistakes, but at the same time,
when we recognize these these mistakes
and
um try to adjust for these mistakes, we
expand the imagination of the monad. And
that's why these secret societies
believe that evil and good exist
together. You can only be good if you do
evil.
Okay? Because e- by committing evil, it
gives you a chance to become better.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
All right. So, we're doing Paradise
Lost.
All right.
This is
um the national epic of the British
Empire.
If you are a member of the British
Empire, which rules the world today, the
Anglo-American Empire, it rules the
world today, if you are an elite member
of the British uh Empire, you memorize
this poem, okay? And it becomes part of
your soul, basically. And it's
it's beautiful, okay? So, this was
written by a man named John Milton.
And John Milton,
he was a rebel. He was a free thinker.
He want he questioned the world. He
thought for himself. And he was a
passionate advocate of free speech.
He was a man who wrote Paradise Lost.
And he wrote it when he was blind.
He could not see.
Therefore, he had to speak it out and
his secretaries had to write it down for
him. As you can see,
well, if a blind man is able to recite
poetry, you must think he is a prophet.
He's a messenger of God. What he is
revealing to you is divine truth. Okay?
All right.
So,
John Milton,
and his most famous work is called
Paradise Lost.
And for Paradise Lost is a foundational
text of many secret societies. They read
this, they discuss this, they worship
this text. And within this text lies the
secrets of the universe.
Okay?
And but only, okay, this is this is
really
uh hard, but only you understand the
secret secret yourself can you see the
secrets it embedded in Paradise Lost.
Okay?
All right. So, what we're going to do is
we will read two speeches by Satan. The
plot of Paradise Lost is really really
simple. It's trying to reimagine
the fall of man. Remember Adam and Eve
in the Garden of Eden,
then they eat that fruit and God
banishes them. Okay? So, Milton is
trying to tell the story again. And he
imagines a serpent who tricks Eve into
eating the fruit as Satan himself. And
Satan was God's uh favorite angel. They
had a fight out. Satan rebelled against
God. God won the war and Satan and the
devils are now banished to hell. And
Paradise Lost begins with the devils
discussing what to do. They've lost this
war against God. They will never ever
defeat God.
Now they're stuck in hell. So, now what
do they do? Some propose that, you know
what? Let's go to Let's just create an
empire.
Okay? Some are like, you know what?
Let's just sit back and enjoy life.
Okay? But Satan is determined to seek
vengeance against God. And so, what he
wants to do is go to the Garden of Eden
and corrupt Adam and Eve and destroy
humanity forever.
Okay? So, they all agree this is a great
plan. But now the question then is,
who's going to go? Because it's
dangerous, right? Because you're
escaping hell, there are angels guarding
hell, but even if you leave hell, you go
into the abyss. You go into space,
right? You don't even You don't even
know where Earth is. You you get lost
for all of eternity. So, no one wants to
go.
So, at this time
when no one wants to go,
Satan steps up and says, "I will go."
Okay? And this is his speech.
"O progeny of heaven, imperial thrones,
with reason have deep silence and demur
seized us. Though undismayed, okay? I
know you guys are scared.
All right? Long is the way and hard that
out of hell leads up to light. Our
prison strong, this huge convex of fire
outrageous to devour immerse us round
ninefold and gates of burning adamant
barred over us prohibit all egress. This
prison is designed to keep us here for
all of eternity. It will be hard to
escape this prison.
These paths, if any paths, the void
profound of unessential night receives
him next, wide gaping and of other loss
of being threatens him plunged in that
abortive gulf. If thence he escape into
whatever world or unknown region, what
remains him less than unknown in dangers
and as hard escape.
Okay? If you can leave hell, you're
still up in the abyss of the universe,
right? You're going to be floating there
for all of eternity. You don't know
where you're going.
But I should ill become this throne, O
peers, and this imperial sovereignty
adorned with splendor, armed with power,
if aught proposed and just a public
moment in the shape of difficulty or
danger could deter me from attempting.
Wherefore do I assume these royalties
and not refuse to reign, refusing to
accept as great a share of hazard as of
honor due alike to him who reigned and
so much to him do of hazard more as he
above the rest. Okay? So, what he's
saying here is really simple.
I'm your leader and therefore I must go.
You have trusted me to lead you for all
of eternity and therefore I will risk my
entire life
to
prove my worth.
High honor sits. Go therefore, mighty
powers, terror of heaven, though fallen,
intend a home while here shall be our
home. What best may ease the present
misery and render hell more to
more tolerable. If there be cure or
charm to respite or deceive or slack the
pain of this ill mention, intermit no
watch against a wakeful foe while I
brought through all the coasts of dark
destruction seek deliverance for us all.
This enterprise none shall partake with
me. I am your leader.
I will go by myself. You guys can just
sit here and like sip, you know, have
some drinks, watch some TV, enjoy
yourself. I don't care, okay? I'm your
leader. I will go by myself to redeem
us, to deliver us from um our torment.
Okay? So, as you can see, this is
heroic. He is the grand hero.
A couple of things I will say about this
speech is, number one, what he's
describing, and secret societies believe
it believe this, is he's describing
his
ascent from hell
as almost
uh our souls leaving our bodies
to the heavens. Okay? And some secret
societies believe that when you die, the
first person you meet is Satan. Because
it is Satan who knows how to take you
from this world, the prison world, to
the light. Because he's do- he's done
this. Okay? So, Satan is very important
part of our journey back to the monad.
That's a Also,
if you study this
um poetry very closely,
you study the imagery, he what he's
describing almost is a baby leaving the
womb, right? Because the baby is a is in
the womb, a prison, and then the baby
escapes. So, secret societies believe
that life and death are the same thing.
To be born, you must die.
And when you die, you are born again.
Okay?
All right.
The other thing is that
these secret societies will use the
speech as an initiation ceremony for
members.
When you join secret society, you must
by yourself choose to fight for all of
humanity by yourself. You must be the
hero.
Okay? You must know when you join secret
society, people will hunt you. People
will want to kill you for speaking the
truth. Do you Do you dare to go on this
journey?
Okay?
So, that's the first speech. The second
speech is much more important. This is a
speech where Satan, the serpent,
convinces Eve
to eat the fruit.
Okay? And this speech is very powerful,
okay? So, I'm going to read really fast
and then explain to you what it means.
"O sacred, wise, and wisdom-giving
plant, mother of science, now I feel thy
power within me clear, not only to
discern things in their causes, but to
trace the ways of highest agents deemed
ever wise." Eve is talking to the
serpent and Eve is is is of course like,
"Hey, what can you speak?"
And the serpent says, "Because I ate
that fruit from the knowledge of good
and evil. It gives you power, okay?" So,
the serpent now wants to convince Eve to
eat that fruit. So, he invokes the power
of the tree, right? "O sacred tree, give
me the power to speak so well that I can
convince Eve to do the impossible."
"Queen of this universe, do not believe
those rigid threats of death. You shall
not die. How should ye? But the fruit it
gives you life unto knowledge. But the
threatener, look on me, me who have
touched and tasted yet both live." Okay?
So, God has warned Eve Adam and Eve, "If
you eat this fruit, you will die."
And the serpent is saying, "No, that's
not true. Look at me. I ate the fruit
and I'm still alive."
"And life more perfect have attained
than fate meant me by venturing higher
than my lot. Shall that be shut to man
which to beast is open? Or will God
incense his ire for such a petty
trespass and not praise rather your
darkness virtue?"
What he's saying saying here is really
important. If he is a true God,
he will reward you for your risk-taking.
Right? He said the fruit will kill you
as a test.
A true God will want you to become
better and better. And you can only do
that by transgressing, by making
mistakes, by disobeying authority.
And And a true God would reward you for
seeking more knowledge.
"Whom the pain of death denounced,
whatever thing death be, deter not from
achieving what might lead to happier
life, not of good and evil, of good how
just, of evil if what is evil be real,
why not known since easier shunned?" We
can only be good people if we know what
evil is.
Right? If you don't know if good and
evil, then you're just stupid.
Okay?
It's because you shun away from evil,
you ignore evil, you fight evil that
you're a good person.
"God therefore cannot hurt you and be
just, not just not God, nor feared then
nor obeyed. Your fear itself of death
removes the fear." Okay? So, he's asking
himself, "Why would God not allow you to
eat that fruit? Why would you all Why
would he keep you low and ignorant, his
worshipers? He knows that in the day you
eat, therefore, your eyes that seem so
clear yet are but dim shall perfectly be
then open and clear and you shall be as
gods."
So, what he's saying is this, there's
two possibilities, okay? Either God is
testing you. God really wants you to
disobey him because that will allow you
to achieve more virtue and knowledge. Or
God is enslaving you and keeping you
ignorant because God is afraid that you
might become God himself.
Okay? So, there's two possibilities.
All right.
What can you not hurt him or this tree
impart against his will of all be his?
Or is it envy and can envy dwell in
heavenly breasts? If he is God, he is in
control of everything. He knows
everything.
Therefore, if you eat this fruit, how
could that possibly challenge him?
Unless he's a false god. Unless he's
tricking you. Unless he is deceiving
you.
Unless he's trying to imprison you.
Okay, that's the only possibility.
Now,
this is
Satan's speech and you and you know, I
took
Milton in college. I was an English
major at Yale and I took in a semester
of Paradise Lost. And at university I
was taught that this speech shows you
how clever and evil Satan is. He's lying
to Eve. God is invincible, omniscient.
You can't eat a fruit and become God.
That's ridiculous. Also, Eve is stupid
because he she believes him, right?
That's what you're taught in university.
That's what you believe.
But, this is really important. When you
actually read the Bible,
Satan is telling the truth.
What What the Satan's logic is what the
Bible says. Okay? A professor at Yale
will tell you that Satan is lying. When
you actually read the Bible by yourself,
you will see he's telling the truth. So,
we're going to read the Bible together,
okay? This is what the Bible says. This
is the word of God.
All right. So, this is Genesis. Now, the
serpent was more crafty than any other
wild animal that the Lord God had made.
He said to the woman, "Did God say you
shall not eat from any tree in the
garden?" Okay? So, in the Bible, this
actually not Satan. It is a serpent.
The woman said to the serpent, "We may
not eat of the fruit of the trees in the
garden, but God said, 'You shall not eat
of the fruit of the tree that is in the
middle of the garden, nor shall you
touch it or you shall die.'" But, the
serpent said to the woman, "You will not
die, for God knows that when you eat of
it, your eyes will be open and you'll be
more like God, knowing good and evil."
Okay? So, this is exactly what Satan
said.
Okay? And this is what the Bible is
saying as well.
Now,
let's move on. Eventually, God banishes
Adam and Eve
for eating the fruit. And you believe
that
they were banished because they
disobeyed God.
But, if you actually read the Bible,
that's not what it says.
For disobeying God, God punishes both
Adam and Eve. Eve, now, when she gives
birth, will suffer pain, right? And Adam
will now have to work hard to grow food.
That's the punishment. The banishment is
not the punishment. So, another question
then is, why were they banished? Again,
let's read the Bible, okay?
So, the woman saw saw
that the tree was good for food and that
it was a delight to the eyes and that
the tree was to be desired to make one
wise. She took of its fruit and ate. And
she was also gave some to her husband
who was with her and she ate. Then the
eyes of both were opened. Okay? So,
Satan is telling the truth. You will not
die. You will learn. You will be become
higher. Okay? Satan was telling the
truth.
All right? So, what So, So, why did God
kick Adam and Eve out? And the Lord God
said, "See, the man has become like one
of us, knowing good and evil. And now he
might reach out his hand and take also
from the tree of life and eat and live
forever." This is why.
There are two trees. The tree of
knowledge, which allows you to have the
mind of God, and the tree of life, which
you lives allows you to live as long as
God. What God is saying is this.
If Adam and Eve eat that
uh tree that fruit from the knowledge of
good and evil and then they eat also a
fruit from the tree of life, they will
be like us.
Satan was telling the truth and God was
lying to Adam and Eve all along.
Okay?
So, now the question then is,
how did Eve know that Satan was telling
the truth?
How did she know?
How?
Well, the problem is if you tried once
and you're wrong, you die, right?
So, how did she know? She was certain
that Satan was telling the truth.
She was certain. Yes. He must be telling
the truth.
Why?
The light in us. You understand? The
true God. The true God still speaks to
us today.
Right?
The false god will lie to us, but inside
you, in your heart, is the is the light
that connects you back to the monad. And
that tells you what is false, what is
true.
Okay? That's how she knew.
All right? So, you guys see Paradise
Lost is now showing us the lost secrets
of the universe.
All right.
So,
um
I'll finish with by talking about the
Nephilim.
In the Bible, it says that the Nephilim
are the children of them from angels and
women, okay? The when people began to
multiply on the face of the ground and
daughters were born to them, the sons of
God saw that they were fair and they
took wives for themselves
of all that they chose. And the Lord
said, "My spirit shall not abide in
mortals forever, for they are flesh.
Their days shall be 120 years." Okay?
So, now God sees Nephilim as a threat as
well.
The Nephilim were on the earth in those
days and also afterward, when the sons
of God went into the daughters of humans
who bore children to them. These were
the heroes that were of old, warriors of
renown. Okay?
This is really important because it
introduces the Nephilim, which is still
around today, okay? According to these
secret societies. But, also, what it's
doing is this. It's telling us
the children, the heroes that are of
old, warriors of renown,
who are they? They're Hercules, they're
Achilles, they're Theseus. They're all
heroes from different mythologies.
Where do they come from? They come from
the mating of angels
and humans. The sons of God, who are
they? They are the old gods. Zeus, Ares,
Apollo. Okay? So, this is the beginning
of monotheism, where the Bible is trying
to destroy polytheistic mythologies and
create one universe where the God is
supreme. Okay? And in this universe,
Zeus now becomes a son of God.
And the children that Zeus has with
mortal women are now called the
Nephilim. So, Hercules is Nephilim.
Okay? So, we'll go into this theme
throughout the semester, where the Bible
is a tremendous act of propaganda that
tries to re- re- invent reality around
one true God.
Okay? But, by doing that, it's denying
our intuition and it's denying the
history of humanity.
All right. Okay. So, we'll continue this
theme next class. Any questions before
we conclude?
Yes.
Well, I think nowadays a lot of us would
pray to God like for getting something
that we wanted, but as you said, like
are we playing like praying to the true
God or the false God? Do we know? Or
like do do we get to know like from our
wishes? Yeah. So, that's a that's a
great question. So,
um according to these secret societies,
okay? The truth is that when you pray,
you're praying to a false god. Where's
the true God?
It's inside you.
Okay? So, don't pray to an outside
force. Look inside to you and ask
yourself, "I know for a fact what is
true.
If I believe in myself enough, then I
will find the truth." Okay? And
actually, that's a theme throughout
Western poetry and literature.
The theme is that we will always be in
conflict with it between the devil and
God, between good and evil.
And what we must do is not say like I
must surrender to God. What we must do
is believe in ourselves. Make mistakes,
but know that
you will eventually find a light because
the light is in you, okay? As long as
you still believe in yourself, all this
all these mistakes you make will become
your strength because they become part
of your wisdom. Okay? That's the divine
truth that these secret societies are
trying to promote. It's okay to make
make make mistakes. It's okay to do
evil,
but listen to the light and the light
will tell you how to redeem yourself.
Okay? The possibility for redemption,
for growth, for imagination is all in us
because of our connection to the monad.
The monad will reward you for believing
in yourself. But, you must first believe
in yourself. And believing in yourself
means often defying authority, making
mistakes, transgression transgression
against rules
of society. Okay? And that's the
ultimate secret that these secret
societies are trying to keep.
All right. Any more questions? That's a
really good question. Thank you.
Well,
well well, the gods
are usually depicted as uh
the most beautiful. Then why uh gods
like Zeus, they will come to
uh human society and uh give birth um
with
um fertilized with the human um
girls.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Okay.
Um, so there So, the question then is,
why are the angels doing this? Okay?
There are two explanations. Okay? So,
the first explanation is these angels
are created by the false god, right? So,
they're they're wicked anyway.
Okay? The second explanation is that
if you're like a hot-looking woman and
you see an angel,
I don't know, man. You know, you're
probably going to want to marry that
person. Okay. All right. Anyway, um if
you're interested in learning more,
there's a book called The Book of Enoch,
which goes into detail about the
Nephilim, okay? But, the Nephilim are
really important topic throughout the
semester because
a lot of secret societies believe in the
Nephilim. And that's And that's going to
motivate them before, okay? Now, what
I've discussed today is how these secret
societies were born.
And as you can see,
um they started off as a noble mission.
But, then the question then is like, how
did they become corrupted over time?
Well, that's something I will discuss
later on, okay? All right. So, I'll see
you guys next class.